is Dave Roberts air with us sure he's
the Dodgers manager are you bored I'm a
little stir-crazy but I think that
fortunately doing family games and some
hallmarks and some movies it's keeping
us occupied right now actually Dan
fortunately we got the green light to
move my son out of his dorm so we're
kind of taking a family up there getting
the stuff out and heading back to San
Diego how often do you stay in touch
with your players every day every day
it's a it's a different group of players
just to kind of catch up by way of text
or a call and I just learned that we're
going to shut down our complex today for
the next two weeks it kind of reassess
and see where we're at and you know
you're trying to be responsible keep
guys going though that want to keep
working in treatment but I think
ultimately you got to be responsible and
shutting down Camelback Ranch and taking
care of the staff is the most important
thing but also I don't know if you get I
we had Joe Maddon on last hour and I
said you're a first-year manager with
the Angels and you're just getting to
know names there you at least have the
benefit of being around these players do
you have a good handle on what kind of
team you think you're going to have this
year absolutely and I think the thing is
that I do I do and I think that's a good
point with Joe and learning is guys and
for me knowing who they are what they're
about and in a time like this although
something completely unprecedented
trusting the fact that they're gonna do
whatever they can to stay in shape and
keep their arms and shape their bodies
in shape and we don't know when this
potential start date if any is going to
happen but I can still you know count on
our guys yeah I was wondering that as
well do you come back and you get to do
spring training for a little while or do
you think you're coming back and you're
gonna be thrown in and you're playing
games right away yeah I think for me and
just kind of speaking logically and and
I just think that it's a two three-week
ramp up and I think that's still
abbreviated so there's got to be some
latitude with the roster size so whether
it's 30 or you
the whole 40 man roster to kind of take
care of the pissed pitching and kind of
been you kind of a week or two later
that you kind of curtail that roster
that active roster to ultimately get
back to 26 but yeah I think then
everything should be on the table I was
talking to my wife earlier this morning
it's like this year is gonna be the year
of amendments and I think that
everything is on the table and has to be
for this year and hopefully there will
be some normalcy at 21
yeah and I'm also curious with what what
position is most affected by this right
now where you're not playing if the
starting pitching you know because I
think that's starting pitching obviously
you've all started pitching but you know
you're talking about when you break camp
you're built up to 90 to 100 pitches and
so these guys are going through their
offseason their winners and getting
ready so to now get the guys built up
through four innings you know looking
back a week ago and then now to kind of
hopefully not go dormant because then
injuries could kind of potentially
happen when you kind of ramped back up
so I think the starting pitching to get
up to whatever is feasible to start a
major league season it's probably a
thing we've got to keep our finger on
and then you look at the NBA and they're
targeting somewhere between June and
August I at what point do you think do
you think there's a drop-dead date for
this season I do I do
I don't know that date I think the NBA
is different because they're you know
what two-thirds of the way their season
done where we're starting anew
potentially and so how much of the
season makes it relevant so I do think
there is a drop-dead point I know that
ideally everyone wanted to get in that
you know 162 or 131 whatever that number
but you know as every day goes on the
more we learn that even more more
unlikely but I'm still you know trying
to hold out hope you driving your life
crazy in so you know what I am NOT
driving her crazy yet she is encouraging
me to go play some golf and some tennis
but now you know what the Gavin do some
you
encouragement mandate in California so
then now the golf course are kind of
being shut down in tennis so I think if
we revisit this conversation pushing it
about a week I think
are you the fastest dad in the
neighborhood so seeing that I live in
the same neighborhood as Carlos Quentin
and my buddy Chad and then who started
mixing watches on the fastest guy yeah I
understand okay
outside of my son my son can can still
beat me in a racer can get me in a race
now that that's a different conversation
when I realize my son is finally faster
than I am how many players are you
faster than on your roster how many
players and my faster that he would
disagree but I know I could be killing
chance no I think I could mean kenley
jansen that's right he felt right now
he's in good shape he's that he's a lean
cool 275 so if I can't be Kenley and
Alex would then I don't know what so
they're not gonna be happy that I called
him out but I'm gonna go Alex would
keneley Julio
I think Clayton can get me and that
might be about I can just bruised our
grata roll - I think I can see you - ray
hey great to check in with you thanks
for joining us and hopefully we'll talk
soon about baseball all right take care
that's Dave Roberts Dodgers manager